we are joined Now by Shelby County
Tennessee district attorney Steve mulroy
his office is the one that brought these
charges in The Tyree Nichols case good
morning to you Steve mulroy we thank you
for joining us today
good morning Gail happy to be here
well we're just hours away from looking
at the video and from what we hear it's
going to be devastating for many people
I'm curious about what led you to the
charges and why you all feel the need to
prepare the public the way you're
preparing them to see this video
well
Gill in any case like this where you
have an officer involved fatality there
is going to be a certain amount of
public agitation but when people
actually see with their own eyes
um the kinds of things that occurred in
this incident there's
there's an even greater potential I
think for a very serious public reaction
and I think that's why it was important
for the charges to be announced prior to
the release of the video and for
expectations to be said and for people
in the community with credibility to
call for com certainly there's room for
protest if people feel the need to
protest but we're hoping that protests
and we're confident I think that that
protest will be peaceful you know
Stephen in the past normally and we've
seen some pretty bad videotapes and it's
always we'll wait let's wait and get the
full story uh the police Union sometimes
steps up and people say wait you have to
wait for a complete investigation that
does not appear to be what happened here
you all saw the tape these officers were
fired then they had been charged with
murder and next we're now being prepared
for the tape can you put it in
perspective about how bad this tape is
and why you are so concerned
yes and and I I want to avoid going to
too much detail about the details of the
case as the prosecutor and I also want
to avoid characterizing the video before
anyone's had a chance to see it
um suffice it to say that
um we believe there was no ambiguity in
the tape and I think people will be able
to judge for themselves once they see it
I don't think on many viewers anywhere
there'll be a lot of debate about
whether the use of force was justified
in this case okay have you ever seen
anything like this before in in your
career
I have not no
and do you think this is a case of five
bad apples we often hear that phrase
It's just five bad apples it's not
reflective of the whole Memphis Police
Department that is certainly what
they're saying do you think it's a case
of that or do you think this really
shows there is a problem with policing
in this country and as Ben Crump says
especially when it comes to dealing with
suspects of color
right I definitely agree with that
latter characterization I think there's
room for some new ones here I mean I I
think it is the case that the majority
of police are uh you know well intended
dedicated well-meaning people but I also
think at the same time it can be the
case that there is a problem with the
overall culture and the overall culture
can sometimes lead to
um overreach on the part of police I
think particularly when the citizen
involved as you said is a person of
color I think what why hope will happen
is that this will spark a broader
conversation about how we can change
that culture how we can improve
supervision on the part of the police
within the police and also independently
like for example civilian review boards
I think what Ben Crum says there's a lot
of Merit to it I think that can be true
at the same time it can also be true
that most police are people of good
faith
yeah I I think Ben Rays is an
interesting point because I think for
many people when they heard about the
case and saw that the officers were
black and the suspect was black Ben said
to me yesterday this could have been
their brother and that's why he said for
many people this will be more painful
for them what do you say about that
well a number of um you know activists
and Community leaders who happen to be
persons of color have themselves said
that they they said that they feared
that
um or expected that the reaction may be
one more of pain and disappointments on
the part of the African-American
Community precisely because of what you
just said I can't speak to that
obviously myself but what I can say is
that there is this expression you know
in the community about you know blue
trumping black I think that we're
talking about an overall culture here
and it doesn't have to be explicit
conscious racist racial discrimination
for it to be a systemic problem and I
think really at the end of the day the
most relevant consideration is not the
race of the officer but the race of the
citizen involved
all right Steve mulroy we thank you for
your time today and I certainly don't
envy you on this day thank you
thank you thank you